i live with an angry manic alcoholic and
things seem to be getting worse
or perhaps it's that my tolerance and
patience levels have diminished
but it's gotten to the point where not
only am i affected by this
but also my family every day is like
walking on eggshells
never knowing when the next bomb is
going to go off but you know it will
he's also had episodes of threatening
suicide and not coming out of the room
for days
when i suggest therapy he poopoos it and
says he will change with diet and
exercise
and will go super extreme and fast for
days or even for a week
sometimes he'll continue to drink beer
while he's fasting but not always
he's told me i'm useless asked if i'm
[ __ ]
etc i know that this is a dis-ease and
i'm trying to stick by him but it's
getting more and more difficult
i certainly do not find it acceptable to
treat me and my sisters in an unloving
way
we have been together for over 20 years
and i've never believed in giving up
but i don't want to live the rest of my
life with this negative energy how can i
help him and myself
uh thank you for the question it's a
super important
um topic subject matter my heart goes
out to you
it's an incredibly difficult situation
and knowing how to navigate it
uh is is
one of the most fraught and emotionally
challenging things i can possibly
imagine so first of all i'm empathetic
to your situation
you're in a very difficult spot and i
can't tell you what you should
or should not do you have to make those
decisions for yourself
but perhaps i can give you a couple
light posts here
and one is first and foremost you have
to
take care of yourself you've got to
figure out how
you know you have to figure out
how to protect yourself and insulate
yourself against
the unhealthy his unhealthy behaviors
and
it's not indulgent for you to do so you
shouldn't feel guilty for doing that
and in fact it's of service to him for
you to do so
the way that you can do that is to seek
out al-anon i think that you would find
great solus
in that program to participate in a
community of people who have
experience going through exactly what
you're going through right now
and understand that there are only so
many things that you can control here
you can control your behavior you can
control
your response to your spouse but what
you can't control
is him or his behavior so to the extent
that you're trying to get him to change
you're in a situation in which that's
very unlikely to occur hopefully he will
reach a point
in his addiction where he will
develop the willingness to try to get
better but from what you've written here
it doesn't sound like he's in that place
right now
he is succumbing to the great obsession
of every alcoholic which is
the effort to try to control your
drinking and he's going through the
machinations and the experimentation
to convince himself that he can do that
whether it's fasting
or exercise his pursuits in those
regards are all
in extremis so it's clear that there are
manifestations of the underlying disease
that he has which is addiction
and your ability to manage or control
that
will result in a lot of unhappiness on
your part
so i think your focus needs to be placed
on yourself
making sure that you're safe and healthy
nobody
should have to submit themselves to that
kind of abuse
whether it's emotional or physical i
can't tell you whether you need to end
the relationship or not
you need to make that decision for
yourself but i can tell you
that you are valuable
in this world and nobody should be
talked to
in that regard so take the steps that
you need to take
to protect yourself and your family
members who are on the receiving end
of this kind of abuse there are
resources available to you
even in the age of covid and again
that's where i think your priority needs
to be in terms of how you communicate
with him
and perhaps be of service to him
you can set healthy boundaries around
what is
and is is not acceptable you can tell
him
look if you speak to me that way again
i'm going to leave or whatever it is
whatever
esteemable act you take on behalf of
yourself to create that boundary i think
is important
and letting him know where that boundary
exists
so that if he disobeys it
or transgresses it then there will be
a ramification or a repercussion whether
that means you leave him or not again
you have to figure out that for yourself
but i think establishing those
boundaries is the first step
in terms of letting him know that his
behavior is not okay
and i think the more specific and
concrete you can be
around that the better it is for
yourself
and for him you can make suggestions hey
listen i think you should go to
treatment you should go to detox you
should
check out aaa you can make those
suggestions but it's important
that you remain divorced from
expectations
as to whether he will avail himself of
that advice
and also any attachment that you have to
outcomes
if you are if you have an expectation
that he's going to get sober or he's
going to do what you're going to what
you
advise him to do then i think you're
setting yourself up for
um for a lot of uh
emotional woe so it's fraught it's very
difficult
especially with loved ones because you
can see
the person beneath the disease and you
are able to hold out hold space
for that individual but sometimes
they're just unable to see it for
themselves
and in truth you can't get an alcoholic
sober
the alcoholic gets sober when the
alcoholic develops the willingness
to take the actions and the steps
required to get sober
and that's a very personal journey so as
harsh as it may sound
this person might have to suffer
greater repercussions might have to
be in more pain than he is in right now
in order to hit that
bottom and have that reconciliation for
himself
you can make yourself available for him
if and when he reaches that point
but you need to protect yourself
emotionally and not make yourself
available for
all of the abuse and the unhealthy
behavior
that he is manifesting at the moment
yeah um heavy the only thing i can add
is you you said safe making sure you're
safe
and i can tell you from my previous
reporting and
things that i've learned is that um
physical abuse doesn't necessarily have
to build up from
like a a push or a slap you could get
you could be in danger already and i
don't want to um
make you hysterical or anything like
that but but
this kind of emotional abuse you're
already on a path
um that you don't want to be on and so i
would in
i don't know if allernon has uh domestic
i'm sure they do have like domestic
abuse counseling
recommendations but i would also i'd
look into some domestic abuse hotlines
that you can yeah maybe we could put
some resources up in the show yeah
and i would call someone asap and i'm
not suggesting
anything other than calling and just
make your own decisions on how you want
to proceed but
you're already in a place that leads to
that could lead to a dangerous situation
for yourself
i think i would add that it's not
i ca i can't diagnose another person as
an alcoholic
you know this anonymous person is saying
her husband is an alcoholic she's
diagnosing him is that maybe he perhaps
admits it
to her i don't know the the
the diagnosis of alcoholism is
is something that only the alcoholic can
can diagnose for themselves
but if this person is an alcoholic and
it would appear that he is
these things don't tend to just get
better they get worse
the best case situation is they stay the
same
but generally they degrade
and devolve and with that
comes a notching up of the abuse
and the unhealthy behaviors that circle
around that
so short of an intervention or
this person developing the willingness
to get better for himself
this is going to continue to progress
and
again that just means that it's all the
more important that you take care of
[Music]
yourself
you